this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and in
this week's episode Jonathan is taking a
look at some of the weapons found in the
multiplayer of 2022's Call Of Duty
Modern Warfare 2. so far I haven't had
to reach for the emotional support so it
is it's it's on the on the edge of curse
this thing and he's making me Twitch
slightly be sure to subscribe as we'll
have another episode that dives into
more of the Modern Warfare 2's
multiplayer weapons and if you'd like to
help with the Royal armies Museum and
continue to support Jonathan's work
check the links in the description of
this video right let's take a look at
the multiplayer weapons of Modern
Warfare 2.
foreign
[Applause]
it has a sight rail on the right on the
left hand side I believe that is found
on some AKs 74 years none of ours have
it though other than that this is pretty
good I mean there are a few little
details I could criticize but unlike
some guns in this game this is a pretty
faithful replication handling of it
looks realistic and good as we would
expect in 2022 from a Call of Duty game
intriguingly intriguing reload here that
I've not seen well I've probably seen it
before somewhere I gather this is based
on something that people do in the real
world so what's happening there if like
me you missed it the first time is that
the firing hand moves to the cocking
handle with the butt in the shoulder
pulls that to the rear so the gun is
empty at this point by the way and then
it rather awkwardly suspending it from
your shoulder you remove the empty
magazine
bitter Fresh Magazine and let the
cooking handle fly forward chambering
the first round because otherwise you
have to
fit the magazine
and separately
[ __ ] the weapon now considering how
quickly you can train to do that I don't
really see the benefit in fact there are
a lot of downsides what is cool though
is that that is a bit of variety based
on something real that has been
incorporated into the game and it's
visually striking it implies extra
knowledge or expertise about how how to
use a gun so I'm all for that kind of
thing
foreign
seeing a an abbreviated bolt action
rifle without a scope but with a light
laser module being used as a sort of CQB
weapon very funky
chassis well yeah I guess it is a
chassis type stock no butt stock I don't
think very short barrel lots of rails
but not really being utilized yeah it's
not kind of in your face but it's a it's
a little bit horrific now I had to
actually have to check this but I
gathered the barreled action is supposed
to be the M24 the the US military sniper
rifle which was in the previous game and
this is a custom stock for it which is
more reminiscent of something like the
something like the M14 Sage stock or
something I don't know if this is
available for the M24 I'd be surprised
all I've ever seen has been a fairly
conventional if polymer stop I'm sure
it's the sniper weapon system is more
modular and advanced than than that but
I don't think it's quite so what's the
word Rayleigh as this one
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
another one we haven't got in the
collection may never get because it's
very very Niche this is an ar57 which is
its real world name in concept only the
receiver set on this looked nothing like
the ar57s I've seen and the lower
receiver appears to be the stock M4 one
from Modern Warfare 2. what's really
interesting is the magazine lying across
the top of the well the hand guard sort
of so this is as the name of Empire AR
armor light rifle five seven and that's
a reference to the round so 5.7 by 28
and this is as the name would imply
again the same round as the fn57 pistol
fires the P90 and not a whole lot else
and that's what this is this is an
attempt by an AR pattern rifle
manufacturer to create a an upper
receiver assembly and I think a complete
rifle as well that allows you to use the
the AR-15 pattern system with the 5.7
wrap so now we see the magazine change
happen on this basically the same as the
real ar57 except that the catch I think
is a rocker type catch on the on the
real gun on this it's a push in you I
think you could make it work with either
on the P90 you have a catch that wraps
around the magazine essentially and so
you go overhand push back this is
awkward this looks awkward to reload I
think your mileage is going to vary on
that one
not tremendously common in the world of
video gaming the belt fed AR I'm not
sure exactly which model is based on but
the Aries shrike I think was the
original modern take on this so this is
where you place your upper receiver with
well as you see there a flip up top
cover feed tray and an open bolt system
so it's a an approximation of that and
what they what I think both of the major
variants around now do is use the
magazine well of the rifle to latch in a
feed box not a magazine but a box to
contain the belt in rounds which is a
clever way to repurpose a feature that
would otherwise be completely pointless
in a now belt-fed gun because there's no
nothing for the magazine world to do so
there's not a great deal I can show you
on this
except for its great granddaddy
the AR-10 support weapon with sure
enough a belt fed
Siva now this system and there are
others Colt came up with it with a
virgin block this system does not is not
drop in drop out of the receiver it is
in fact both upper and lower receivers
modified
I do enjoy the the cartridge ejection
thing there I'm not actually sure I'm
not familiar enough with Marlin rifles I
believe it's in Marlin 95. the popping
out the cartridge catching it and
inspecting it whether that's easy to do
or not Marlin owners please let me know
but it certainly does look pretty slick
foreign
[Music]
I haven't had to reach for the emotional
support uh Stone cover I'm hopeful I can
make it through this whole thing without
needing to this is getting a little
close though starting with that absurd
muzzle break on the front of the rifle
lever actions really should be left
playing in my view but that's that's
fighted by the rail system that I
suppose is tolerable the huge scope I'm
not even sure I feel like a 20
magnification or something it is
excessive and then is should be
basically negated by the ridiculous cut
off pistol grip style well it's just a
grip it's not a stop so it is it's it's
on the on the edge of curse this thing
and is making me Twitch slightly oh I
see so that muzzle break is meant to be
from a 338 caliber rifle well that makes
sense would that would that help with
4570 which is correctly it says based on
the shape of the um ejection report on
it that seems to be correct I guess it
would help but it would add excessive
weight relative to yeah you don't
typically see rifles of this type with a
great big dfr type 338 muzzle brake on
it yeah I think I can just about live
with this the grip underneath is a
little this tasteful
right at long last we actually have part
of the collection here
a Benelli M4 super 90 and there was much
rejoicing because this thing is
something of a benchmark for modern
tactical shotguns so which does mean I
can compare it to the one in the game
and again it seems to be different the
the shape of the ejection Port is way
more rather way more significantly more
squared off on the game gun and what
what I would normally say is a nice
touch of light being visible through the
cocking slot at the rear here it's
because when you're reloading it or
seeing through through the bottom of the
gun which is open to the daylight so
you'd see light coming up well we
wouldn't on this because the receiver is
machined metal it's very thick in this
area so it's a very minor detail but at
the same time it makes it not feel like
the like the M4 we'll just point out
suppressors on shotguns are not common
but they are a thing might even be might
even make a bit of a comeback and become
maybe not standard but a bit more common
than they are as we with anything sort
of large large bore and loud you're not
going to get the same level of sound
suppression as you would with with a
pistol say but it is surprisingly
effective from what I understand so it's
not out it's not as wacky as it might
look to see a big old Square modern
suppressor on the end of this thing
well that's interesting
there's someone someone built this for
me
it's got a skull on it
now this is partly in honor of a ghost
but uh you know from from Call of Duty
but I do like skulls uh it's mostly
black but has red on it and it's an AR
rifle these are some of my favorite
things this is almost like the opposite
of cursed it's absolutely not what you
do with any kind of fighting rifle but
if I was to customize a gun in a game
rather than slavishly sticking with
something stock or realistic as I tend
to do I'd probably make this
one of my favorite Firearms of all time
as some of you know the MP5 except it's
not now has the gun itself uh I've
grabbed something pretty similar here
mp5a3 and it happens to be in the same
configuration except for the lack of
rails on the forehand as the I won't
call it an Abomination because it's not
completely cursed but for an uh MP5 fan
like me it's pretty far removed biggest
issue for me would be the magazine well
area it's far too wide in reality it's
as wide as it needs to be to fit this
magazine
going along with that is the horrific I
don't know what I don't know what to
compare it to but a gigantic magazine
catch which sits here which is where the
real sort of secondary magazine catch
sits on the MP5 that nobody uses that's
they have a semi or us semi-automatic
only version like an HK 94 where that's
your only magazine patch actual users of
this thing use the
paddle magazine release which is not on
this gun so pretty disappointed with the
MP5 in Modern Warfare 2 2022
foreign
[Applause]
shape with the longer leverage which
this doesn't need but anyway it's not
bad it's just a rod I mean you could
replace the cocking handle with a
cylindrical Rod like that but why would
you it does make it look pretty weird so
we see a version of the reload there
where we get a Fresh Magazine inserted
we slap the cocking handle to chamber
the round that's how you're supposed to
use it we then see a press check of the
chamber that's what you definitely don't
want to do with an HK roller locked
system you you don't have a means of
forward assisting that to make sure it's
now fully shut your rollers might ever
so slightly out of Engagement which
means the gun's not going to fire so you
do not want to be doing a press check on
this system
good grief that's one of the more
energetic revolver spins that I've seen
in some time and uh looking at these
things they're pretty elaborate we've
got some sort of a clamp on compensator
on the front so a laser aiming module
clipped around trigger guards that's the
real technology that has existed for a
while now yeah they're looking a bit
they're looking a bit sci-fi these these
things the base gun is very close to the
Smith and Wesson model 500 which I very
much like to have in the collection if
you don't have yet the barrels though
are really very different I'm not sure
if those are I don't think those are
based on anything real certainly nothing
from the Smith Wesson 500 range okay not
only are the guns I think customized I
don't think these are stock they are
firing shot and really powerful shots
that we have just completely destroyed
panel van in a few shots where to start
well shots snake shot is a thing called
snake shot because it's for defending
itself from venomous snakes Inc
increases the chance of you hitting them
The Recoil from these rounds is
excessive I would suggest but hey maybe
I guess the case capacity of 500 magnum
these are sort of Full House loads that
have the same mass as a bullet but in
shots for that makes sense to you yeah
so highly unrealistic
[Music]
we have a decent effort at the reload
animation here we are releasing the
cylinders one-handed and emptying the
guns still with them in your hands but
we do then have the off-screen cheat of
somehow maybe we have a pet monkey or
something who is feeding rounds into the
cylinders and then you snap them shut
and there you are reload it so it looks
more plausible than some dual wheeled
reloads that I've seen But actually
would be basically impossible to pull
off without the trained monkeys
foreign
six also known as the lynx we have an M1
in fact you can see that on display here
at leads as part of our film and TV
display because that was actually loaned
out and used in the TV series Spooks
randomly before it was part of a museum
collection this is obviously
semi-automatic it's long recoil so the
barrel you know recoils significantly
far back into the gun and it has to
recoil the full length of a cartridge to
be able to extract and eject hence that
long chunk cycling which is which is
well done it has that big magazine that
rides up a rail to lock into place but
like the old Tommy Gun Magazine did
pretty effective against people in the
game but uh surprisingly ineffective
against the helicopters many many shots
going in there without seeming troubling
the helicopter over much that's just of
course because helicopters have to have
a number of hit points to be any use at
all in a video game and so it always
doesn't matter what you're using it's
never going to have that decisive clout
that are real or well even a full 50
caliber round would actually have if you
put that into the engine of a helicopter
you would be putting it into instant
difficulty it doesn't just shrug it off
until it's hard 10 of them hit it and
then it suddenly starts spewing smoke
that's just a limitation of a non-super
realistic video effect
thank you
all right everyone those were more guns
from Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2-2 um
if you'd like to support what we do at
the Royal armories you can head over to
our various social media Outlets you can
check out the website for that and we
also have our own YouTube channel
um featuring fairly prominently me uh
should that interest you at all and more
guns importantly thanks again for
watching and you can join me in my
promotional support MP5 next time
[Music]
thank you